et pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
megaman chef du service de réanimation
de l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
bonsoir à vos côtés linde numéro cage
professeur des universités spécialiste
de l'éducation psychologue bonsoir alors
linn ullmann blocage pas de changement
dans les écoles prévu la situation est
sous contrôle assure ce soir jean-michel
bloquèrent on a entendu un l'inquiétude
des enseignants également face à cette
crise sanitaire quel est votre regard
sur l'état d'esprit des enseignants
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que le
gouvernement pourrait leur proposer
selon vous alors le regard qu'on peut
porter correspond tout à fait à ce que
votre enquête a laissé paraître c'est à
dire une certaine anxiété à la fois pour
le métier qu'ils ont à faire est ce
qu'ils peuvent continuer à enseigner
dans ces conditions et pour leurs élèves
qui à la fois ne peuvent pas maintenir
la distanciation physique mais aussi ne
peuvent pas forcément à prendre dans de
bonnes conditions
et puis également pour eux mêmes et pour
les conditions dans les qualités et
exerce alors est ce que le gouvernement
peut intervenir il ya sans doute des
choses à faire très certainement parce
que les conditions dans les écoles sont
ne sont pas satisfaisantes du tout en
l'état actuel et la difficulté et
l'anxiété pour les enseignants s'est
malgré tout dit d'essayer de maintenir
le sens de leur métier c'est-à-dire
enseigner et comment le faire dans ces
conditions là qu'à la fermeture des
écoles qui ne semble pas à l'ordre du
jour
c'est une bonne chose pour les élèves
selon vous oui pour les élèves je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose parce que
j'ai eu l'occasion dans le cadre d'une
recherche qui a été qui est soutenu par
l'aef d'interroger des élèves pendant la
période du confinement il est apparu
qu'ils arrivaient à s'en sortir et qu'il
ne faisait preuve de beaucoup
d'inventivité et de créativité donc
qu'ils arrivent à apprendre
malgré la distanciation effective et
dans laquelle il se trouvait au moment
du confinement mai
il eu besoin de l'aide à que pouvait
leur apporter leurs enseignants quel que
soit le niveau de classe en fait il
ressorti comme un élément incontournable
pour eux et puis arrivé également on
pourrait dire en 2d le fait de pouvoir
rencontrer leurs amis d'être avec les
autres et donc de se développer dans les
échanges qu'il pouvait avoir avec bruno
mary germann fin septembre vous faisait
partie d'un groupe de médecins à vous
demander des mesures radicales un
prouvèrent face au regain de l'épidémie
de corona virus couvre-feu leur
confinement locale ce sont des mesures
aujourd'hui qui sont sur toutes les
lèvres de bonne mesure selon vous où
elles sont nécessaires
alors on va dire des fins et ans nous
demandions à la population d'être plus
stricts et plus responsable dans le
comportement quotidien
c'est à dire d'appliquer mieux les
mesures barrières le port du masque non
seulement dans l'espace public mais
également dans l'espace privatif c'est à
dire lorsqu'il y à des rassemblements
amicaux où des rassemblements familiaux
élargi car c'est ce ce cercle privé
constitue est constitué le lieu
principal des contaminations à l'époque
évidemment nous ne demandions nullement
de mesures plus draconiennes
on pensait que la simple
responsabilisation pourrait permettre de
stabiliser voire d'infléchir les courbes
de contamination force est de constater
que depuis maintenant deux mois
les contaminations augmente à une
vitesse certes lente mais néanmoins
constante avec désormais une arrivée
importante de patients vers les services
d'urgence et de réanimation
les jeunes qui s'étaient contaminés au
départ ont désormais transmis le virus
vers des personnes plus âgées qui
malheureusement présente désormais des
formes plus graves
venant à l'hôpital aujourd'hui en ile de
france environ 45 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des
patients présentant des formes graves de
kobe tu donc très
logiquement évidemment pour pouvoir
casser la coupe de contamination il est
attendu que le gouvernement prenne des
mesures désormais un peu plus strictes
évidemment pour éviter que le système de
santé s'effondre dans deux ou trois mois
et qu'il faille recourir au confinement
généralisée comme un couvre-feu par
exemple vous êtes pour alors je peux pas
me prononcer évidemment si je suis pour
ou contre c'est pas c'est pas dans ces
termes je ne dispose pas bien sûr ni des
chiffres ni des données permettant de
prendre une décision
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'effectivement le principe du couvre
feu c'est de restreindre la nuit la
circulation et l'interaction sociale
entre les individus
car de fait évidemment on peut pas
légiférer et interdire les réunions dans
le cercle privé
donc ce sont des mesures qui ont
démontré leur efficacité dans d'autres
pays elles sont d'ailleurs appliqué
actuellement en allemagne y compris un
niveau de circulation du virus plus
faibles donc je dirai ce sont des
mesures à mona de bon sens je pense
elles ne viennent pas trop tard elles
permettront malgré tout de freiner dans
une certaine mesure la progression de
l'épidémie et on l'espère évidemment
permettent de sauver le système de santé
pour qu'ils puissent maintenir son offre
de soins la totalité de la population
alors avec des soignants qui sont de
plus en plus nombreux on le disait ces
derniers jours à vouloir quitter
l'hôpital parce que c'est trop dur parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de moyens on disait
tout à l'heure effectivement que les
enseignants également avait eu une
baisse de moral est ce qu'on peut
craindre une fuite des enseignants dans
les semaines dans les mois à venir selon
vous l'inhumain blocage par rapport à
cette situation sanitaire que nous
sommes en train de vivre
je ne sais pas exactement ce que vous
entendez par fuite
j'ai pas ce qui est des tas d des
enseignants qui partirait finalement
face à une situation à un métier qui est
devenu trop joue trop dur trop
contraignant aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on en
est là aujourd'hui dans l'éducation
nationale
alors effectivement je n'ai les
décisions sont difficiles je pense un
pour certains on peut se retrouver dans
des cas de ré interrogations du sens
qu'ils donnent à leurs métiers je ne
crois pas que dans la majorité des
enseignants veulent forcément fuir ce
métier parce que ils ont plutôt au
contraire conscience de la place qu'ils
ont dans ce qui se passe en ce moment et
de leur rôle
donc je pense que c'est plutôt un
comportement de responsabilité qui se
dégage des enseignants et moi dans les
contacts que j'ai pu avoir les
recherches que nous avons menées sur
cette question il y avait au contraire
une très grande préoccupation relative
au sens à donner à leur métier dans la
majorité des cas compte tenu de ces
nouvelles conditions
c'est à dire que des enseignants se
posaient vraiment les questions de ce
qu'on appelle la dit d'activation de
leur enseignement c'est à dire comment
continuer à enseigner quand on est à
distance alors qu'on a tout préparé pour
une activité qui doit se dérouler en
présentiel dont classe ce sont des
questions qui se posent
on leur demande de penser des courants
terme d'hybridation ils le font
remarquer qu'il leur manque du matériel
il ya un problème d'équipement de deux
d'accès à certaines on va dire certaines
conditions ne serait ce que pour avoir
la distance d'avoir internet de pouvoir
être abonnés d'avoir un flux suffisant
pour pouvoir répondre à ces conditions
là donc dans une telle position je ne
crois pas que les gens est envie de
quitter leur métier mais ils demandent
d'autres conditions de travail ça c'est
c'est plutôt la revendication de la
majorité des enseignants
il y a également le souci des élèves et
tout à l'heure il était question
peut-être d'envisager der confinement
même localiser compte tenu des
conditions qui peuvent se trouver à
l'intérieur dans le privé dans les
familles ce qui est ressorti de
l'enquète si que pour certains enfants
qui vivaient dans des appartements ou
dans des maisons
le fait d'être confiné avait été une
solution intéressante parce qu'ils
pouvaient avoir d'autres liens avec
leurs familles des liens qu'ils
n'avaient plus mais dans d'autres cas
c'était plutôt des conditions
extrêmement difficiles et on a craint
pour certains enfants qui se
retrouvaient dans des appartements
réduit avec des familles et au niveau
psychologique
il ya probablement des effets de cette
situation une home & garden est-ce que
la problématique des effectifs à venir
est ce que vous vous le craignez c'est
une vraie question aujourd'hui un manque
de personnel soignant pour faire face à
cette seconde vague
oui tout à fait on va dire au cours du
premier pic épidémique l'épidémie
atteint deux régions principalement le
grand est et la région ile de france
et lorsque nous avons dû ouvrir en
catastrophe un nombre important de lits
de réanimation
lorsqu on est sortis des murs c'est à
dire lorsqu'on a mis des lits dans des
secteurs qui n'étaient pas initialement
dédiée à l'animation nous avons reçu des
renforts venant d'autres régions et
venant de cliniques privées
malheureusement cette fois-ci l'épidémie
touche la totalité du territoire
national et donc il est très peu
probable que l'on puisse bénéficier
d'une d'une telle aide venant de
l'extérieur
il faut donc compter uniquement sur ses
ressources internes et malheureusement
comme vous le dites
le personnel soignant et en nombre
limité il ya un manque chronique
notamment de personnels spécialisés en
réanimation et donc effectivement ça
peut être le point de difficulté pour
pouvoir augmenter le capacitaire de lit
en réanimation
alors il faut compter en plus sur la
fatigue est peut-être la démotivation de
certains personnels malgré tout nous
ferons tout en notre possible avec les
moyens disponibles pour soigner la
totalité des patients qui les locaux
vides ou non merci beaucoup bruno meyer
man je rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service de réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière merci à vous line numa
bocage professeur des
cité spécialiste de l'éducation et
psychologues